I give up way too difficult I just stood
there next door and I couldn't do
anything I couldn't even speak to her oh
my god Eric come on hey guys I'm Eric I
recently moved to New York and it's a
little hard to make friends here
everyone's like always in a rush people
are hard to talk to I don't know I feel
like I'm maybe it's my fault I feel like
I'm intruding or like I don't know what
to talk to people about so I just don't
feel like I'm connecting with anyone so
I'm just gonna I'm gonna break my wall
and I'm gonna try to make more friends
today by talking to a hundred strangers
this is scary okay Eric how's it going
man hey man how's it going cool if I sit
here oh cool man I'm just trying to meet
people you play chess you know no quiet
lunch all right dude it's good it's good
I'm Eric nice to meet you
don't talk when people are eating okay
okay I'm sorry nice to meet you though
what do I talk to man I don't think
anybody wants to talk to me hey guys
what's up hey guys from here yeah I'm
new I'm sorry to make this art I've been
here like two months trying to make
friends so I'm literally just going to
the park and like talking to people it's
really awkward yeah really
oh you guys are the best all right I'm
gonna do it Eric nice to meet you I'm in
from Philly yeah yeah yeah this is cool
if I sit down
perfect what are you reading what's that
about
okay yeah sure where you guys from
Israel no way I just want on birthright
it is it cool if I watch oh dude thank
you guys can I hear Paul yeah man how
did you get into juggling where do you
go to school oh that's awesome
yeah design stuff yeah that's crazy I've
never I don't think I've ever met a
butchie's Asst oh my god you're smart as
hell working for Macbeth right now is an
ensemble trying to really develop this
without a director I'd love to sometime
maybe take a lesson or something do you
guys have cards or it is not fine yeah
let me get your number how'd you decide
to just start like this like writing
poems on the street before sunrise
no I'm talking through the dull feet and
this just them like I leave a
conversation there two hours yeah and
they're walking along
this guy costs them and says hey like
let me write you a poem I could do that
so the next day I went out sign dude
this getting easy I'm getting good at
this
the next few hours were incredible I met
so many interesting people and I hope
this video can lessen the stigma behind
talking to strangers because it truly is
by opening
I mean strangers fed me a bagel okay and
there was just so much positive energy
and joy everyone was laughing having a
good time and I ended up adding a
hundred people on Instagram who I
genuinely want to stay in touch with I
know this is getting cheesy but I
experienced something awesome and I hope
everyone can see how much you love this
world has to offer
I just feel like I'm in love with
strangers now I just want to talk to
strangers all the time just like how's
it going man good excited okay good good
good
[Music]